[Music]
now the speaking program begins after
lunch but I thought I ought to say a
word about the packages you find on your
chairs or found on your chairs instead
of the usual program booklet published
in association with the dedication of a
new building we published a box okay
some who seen the building will
recognize a certain similarity in shape
and design that a building itself a
design inspired by artists artist
Kenneth Nolan's color treatment of the
walls this box this box and its contents
are sign and symbol of the building and
of its occupants we hope you will enjoy
this contemporary time capsule doc
Edgerton buried one last night we have
produced one this morning in the box
you'll find brochures and artifacts
produced by and describing the
activities of the three major programs
in that building the media laboratory
the Council for the Arts at MIT and the
Albert and Vera list Visual Arts Center
whose programs are overseen by the
Committee on visual arts and its staff
in the box there is a feast for both
eyes and ears I should say also that
there is this book which describes the
artist architect collaboration that was
involved in the building it will fit in
the box but you won't find it in the box
yet it's at the reception this afternoon
and I urge you to pick up a copy this
afternoon at the reception so please
enjoy the the box please enjoy your
lunch
not in a box but we are pressed by the
program for the rest of the afternoon
and late afternoon and it seems a good
moment to begin we come together today
forum a remarkable occasion the building
we are dedicating this afternoon is
extraordinary
both in concept and in execution the
people who are working in this building
are likewise exceptional a cast of
energetic creative visionaries drawn
from disparate fields of art and science
to pursue a common purpose that purpose
is fundamentally the advancement of the
art the quality and the depth of human
communications and the people for whom
we name the building this afternoon
Gerry and Leo Wiesner are equally
special in their wisdom in their vision
in their caring for MIT and for how this
institution and its people can
contribute to a better world I can think
of no more appropriate way to mark the
important place that Gerry and Leia hold
in the life of MIT and to reflect their
40-year commitment to the fields of art
of the Arts and communication than to
name this building in their honor
may I take just a moment however to draw
your attention to still another
remarkable assembly those individuals
and corporations and foundations nearly
100 of them and all who have entered
into partnership with the Institute to
create a vital new facility to house
programs in arts and media technology we
are most grateful for their gifts not
only a building funds of program support
and equipment but equally for gifts of
foresight and intellect because of their
generous support of a shared vision we
have today on our campus a window into
the future we will be saying a bit more
about the individual donors later in the
day I would like to say a few words here
about our corporate and foundation
benefactors they come from fields of
interests seemingly distant from each
other and they represent a
remarkable melding of industrial and
philanthropic endorsement of this new
and exciting venture the companies for
the most part are new friends to the
Institute they are partners in areas of
research characterized by the
intersection of print video and computer
media these industrial sponsors see
their future as partly or largely vested
in the creative use of new technologies
for human communication I wish we had
time at this point to ask each of the
corporate representatives to stand for
our recognition but we will be paying
tribute to them at the ceremonies in the
weasoner building later in the day I
should tell you though that these
corporate donors range from giants and
television broadcasting and newspaper
and magazine publishing to many of the
world's most prominent electronics
companies from pioneers in photography
and film and video to leaders in
acoustics and sound systems from
foundations whose grants and gifts most
commonly support laboratory research in
science and engineering to foundations
who are most often associated with
support of the fine arts I would like to
take this occasion however to single out
just two of these notable institutions
the first is a major industrial donor
the NEC corporation of Japan whose
generosity allowed us to conclude this
project you will hear from the NEC
chairman dr. Koji kobayashi during our
afternoon symposium his corporate
philosophy on computers and
communications is in clear harmony with
our vision of media technology and we
are most grateful for that communion the
other institutional donor I want to
mention came in right at the beginning
of the project the National Endowment
for the Arts provided early and welcome
support in the form of a major grant in
support of the pioneering experiment
among architect IM Pei and artists Scott
Burton Richard flash nur and Kenneth
Noland in the design of the building we
are extremely grateful for that early
vote of confidence in an experimental
collaborate collaboration that has
produced such stunning results and I'm
delighted that we have with us today a
representative of that agency
he is mr. Hugh southern deputy chairman
of the National Endowment for the Arts
he has agreed to say a few words on
behalf of the agency and on behalf of
its chairman mr. Frank SM Hudson mr.
southern good afternoon I'm first of all
I bring greetings from frank hodsoll who
was scheduled to be here originally and
unfortunately at the last moment
couldn't make it but for me that's very
great pleasure since it meant that I got
to make this visit instead I want first
of all thank David Saxon chairman of the
MIT corporation Paul Gray the president
John torch the provost and John Durham
also Dean of the School of Architecture
and planning for giving me and the
agency this opportunity I'm delighted to
assist in dedicating this magnificent
building designed by one of the 20th
century's greatest architects I am Pei
and we at the endowment had the great
honour of his being a member of the
National Council for many years as you
can see this is going to be throughout a
tribute to one or another kind of
collaboration I think it's fitting to
that the building is named for two
ramens layer weasoner great figures at
MIT for many years and and also
important figures and significant
contributors to many aspects of our
national life dr. Wiesner
have set an example of public service in
in
many different arenas that would spend
the rest of the afternoon if I recounted
them among llamas public science advisor
to President Kennedy and we believe to
that he's done as much as anyone to make
MIT one of the great institutions of its
kind not only in the United States but
in the world the building will be a
tribute to him and also a think a
testament to his leadership for a long
time to come we're delighted too that
the National Endowment through a 1979
challenge grant had a role in the
building's creation and also that in
1980 the art in public places grant
referred to just now to assisted in a
highly successful artist architect
collaboration integrating works of
kenneth noland richard flash Nair and
Scott Burton into the overall design of
IM Pei
it's nice when one thinks of macro
grants like challenge grants and what
they can do to make a building project
comes alive but it's even I think more
satisfying to us to recall a very modest
grant that led to such magnificent and
such a magnificent outcome the building
and the programming that it will contain
is important to our agency for many
reasons first it's an outstanding
example of public and private
partnership in the artistic creation
it's an example
it's an exemplary piece of architecture
and design we think that the issue of
collaboration between arcus artists and
architects is an issue that is very much
alive and that this may be a forerunner
of many further such collaborations
within the building the Hayden and list
galleries of themselves wonderful spaces
for the exhibition of art we're glad to
pay tribute in that connection to Kathy
Holbrook the director whose highly
regarded in our halls and most helpful
to us too she is now on the overview
of the visual arts program and finally
we think that the list Center represents
a wonderful example of public access to
the best in contemporary art the Media
Lab is a major Centre for the pioneering
in new and complex relationships between
arts and media technology I think that
one of the things that artists and
scientists have in common is that the
underlying method is that of trial and
error and to see those conceptually
united in a building where the work that
will be done will be open-ended
will be exploratory will be speculative
reflects the bringing together of the
most creative elements of both worlds
the building is now part of a growing
international network of academic
centers exploring media and arts
technology the Institute - Rajesh of :
ASIMO acoustic music at the center
Beaubourg in Paris the Center for
computer studies in music at Stanford
University and in other places in the
world and this facility so far as the
endowment is concerned there some of you
might judge this to be more an example
of mi t--'s creative grantsmanship than
of the actual interests of our agency I
think I'd like to correct that and say
that one of the reasons why mi t--'s
applications to us are very frequently
successful is because we enormous ly
respect both the artistry and
professionalism of proposals has made to
us and that that view has been shared by
many of our panels over a long period of
time and confident that it will continue
to be so in the future our museum
program has supported the permanent
collection in new exhibitions is also
dealt with some issues museum technology
our visual arts program has dealt with
exhibition space for innovative
contemporary artists it supported
graphics projects the inter arts program
has dealt with interdisciplinary
experimentation performance art and
other genres the media arts with film
making especially with those concerned
with new technologies such as spatial
imaging the design arts program has
treated this as a model situation for
design competition literature has with
you explored the possibilities for
electronic publishing music has
supported projects dealing with
computer-based experimental music and
art and education has been involved with
community resource projects generated
out of MIT as you can see the diversity
the richness the texture the intense
investigation the inquiry the
intellectual curiosity that this range
represents is something that I think
brings our agency and MIT very close
together finally I want to say a word
about the future I think that art has a
place in ameliorating what was referred
to refills mooring the possibility for
alienation in in in society I think that
art and science together are likely to
be more humane science and less
self-centered art and I think that the
future collaboration of this building
and the people and the ideas and the
inventions that it will house are
immensely hopeful signal for this campus
for the city and indeed for the entire
nation thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much mr. southern now it
is with particular pleasure and respect
that I introduce to you a man who
already occupies a place in the pantheon
of mi t--'s great figures he is our
former president and former chairman of
the corporation a man whose own vision
of MIT special role in transcending the
several cultures is brought closer by
the building we dedicate today he is dr.
James R Killian jr. who will introduce
another of our luncheon speakers Jim
president gray ladies and gentlemen for
an old hand who's been around a couple
of hundred years this is certainly a
joyous occasion knowing as I do all the
great efforts and planning and dreams
that brought us to this place today it
is joyous too because I counted a
privilege to say a few words a quite
personal word or two about our speaker
today for 40 years we have been friends
and colleagues at MIT and Accord over
century ago in the corridors of power in
Washington it all started this way and
putting my files and papers together for
transfer to the MIT archives I found a
long-forgotten letter I wrote in 1945 to
a mr. reasoner a young engineer on the
staff of MIT to wartime radiation
laboratory in part this letter said the
following dear doc mr. Eisner I wish to
confirm the offer which president
professor Hazen
as discussed with you a position in our
Department of Electrical Engineering we
take pleasure in inviting you to join
the Institute star as an assistant
professor for three years and then this
came the important part we look forward
with much pleasure to having you join us
at the Institute we believe that
opportunities over the coming years in
your field will be of ample scope to
your work I hardly know of new in 1945
how happily prophetic my letter actually
was but here we are today this greatest
gathering assemble to celebrate the
accomplishments of mister Wiesner whom I
addressed trying to lure him to MIT it
is a great good fortune for science for
technology for the Arts for MIT that
this young engineer said yes my personal
and collegial relationships that was to
bring the two of us together as
colleagues and MIT occurred as you heard
just a minute ago in Washington when we
both served on the staff of presidents I
as science advisor to President
Eisenhower and dr. Weiser no powering a
science advisor to President Kennedy I
think it of interest that we had in the
Disciplinary relationships in the
politics of those days because dr.
weasoner served on the Eisenhower
Science Advisory Committee and I they
did a job for him on President Kennedy's
Committee so there were no political
barriers between the scientists who
served the presidents
in those days these experiences in the
domain of presidential advice were
pioneering experiences that contributed
importantly to our own self development
and to our affection for each other and
our sense of mutual national goals it
was not long long after he joined the
faculty of the Institute the dr.
weasoner was appointed director of the
research laboratory of electronics a
successor to the big wartime radar
laboratory which had recruited him from
the Library of Congress this was the
first of the great interdisciplinary
laboratories established for the
Institute and he set a pattern for our
new policies concerning the conduct of
research and learning during dr. weasels
leadership he brought to this laboratory
an interdisciplinary congeniality that
attracted not only artists and other
creative talents but a truly
extraordinary array of philosophers
linguist artists communication
specialists linguist and whatnot that
found this laboratory a stimulating
place to have contact with and in which
to work out of the residents are
prompted by Norbert Wiener of the great
mathematicians brilliant mathematics and
the inspiration weasoner gained from it
came a new sense a deeper sense of human
communications that invigorated our
programs and engineering the
neurosciences psychology linguistics
computation technologists and the arts
dr. weasoner move rapidly of course from
the RLE experience to important
administrative post at the Institute and
finally as we all know to the presidency
a position which he filled with
extraordinary acclaimed brilliance this
was the period when MIT was emerging as
a great Research Center holding the
place holding a place among the
institution's in the forefront of the
world's great research universities
these responsibilities much-needed
resources particular resources to
establish new programs to achieve new
integrations among the arts and
technology the social sciences and the
sciences clearly he understood what
Professor Thomas Kuhn of our philosophy
department meant when we said when he
said we have only begun to discover the
benefit of seeing science and art as one
this sense of kinship as once long ago
was once long ago we're looking up they
stated by William James the great
philosopher in his off fortieth
statement that the idea is the union of
the mathematician with the poet fervour
with measure passion with correctness
and we've seen that ideal and permeate
this institution our accolades today for
dr. and mrs. reasoner is an expression
of our understanding of how great has
been their influence and how major their
efforts to achieve what I can rightly
call an awe-inspiring advancement in the
way this institution is moving toward
the University of the future it is hard
for me to speak about dr. Wiesel
in actual terms because our friendship
and our sense of allegiance to all the
great purposes of the Institute and of
learning has been so close and so long
sustained he is a friend and colleague
are cherished beyond measure
and I count myself among those who
greatly admire his partner lair Wisner
has shared his life and his ideas and
ideals and efforts in an extraordinary
way in the Old Testament book Oh famous
the question is asked can two walk
together except they be agreed clearly
Geri and lair have walked together in
Thor agreement in the service of this
institution and in the developments
bringing us together today thus in
introducing dr. weasoner
I emphasized our eminently suitable it
is not the glories of our new arts and
media technology where the names of both
with these feelings of affection I
present dr. Jerome B weasoner fully
aware that those who love him call him
Jerry he will speak on creating with
computing dr. Wisner
[Applause]
thank you Jim this day and the events
yesterday keep reminding me of a
television program called this is your
life
and I keep wanting to correct the
exaggerations that go by but I'll do
that another time there are a couple
things I would like to say though you
don't know how important lay I was to my
existence at MIT I was working in
Washington for Archibald MacLeish and
quite happy or unhappy alternately and
the job it was war had begun and I was
feeling that what I was doing even
though it was helping to set up the
office of facts and figures which was
going to be our propaganda agency for
the war was not really quite a technical
challenge all I was doing as signing
requisitions to RCA for equipment and I
figured somebody else could do that
because you either bought their
equipment or you didn't get anything so
you didn't have much choice and but I
got a letter from Sam gouge Schmidt who
had been a professor of mine at Michigan
I think encouraged by Louis smullin who
had been a graduate student colleague
inviting me to come to the radiation lab
and I wrote a letter saying I would love
to do it but I was extraordinarily busy
I didn't write it I dictated it
fortunately so
go out and I went home that night
totally about this and she looked at me
with that scowl she can get when she
knows what I'm doing is foolish and she
said I thought you wanted to get back to
something a lot more technical and I
said yes and I went back in the morning
and I thought up that letter and I wrote
a letter to Sam saying I'd love to come
and I came and that's the way one's life
gets changed when you have somebody
sensible around you all the time the
title of my speech creating with
computing started out as thinking with
computing as suggested by the program
managers
I thought maybe creating wasn't more
interesting and easier subject to deal
with I must say I've learned that you
can't really deal with either but I will
deal with it
as I've gone through verb drafts of this
paper
I have done it on computer and then
young ladies in my office have tried to
make English out of it and edit it and
each time we've gone through a cycle
they've given it a new name so that we
could tell one from the other and this
was put in my briefcase last night and
on the disk was the title let's hope I
suspect - that's not a bad idea for all
of us the title and creating with
computing obviously raises an infinity
of questions such as who created what
and why and even what is meant by the
word creating and if I had another hour
I'd tell you about my dictionary
research on that simple word we heard on
some other words this morning in history
well there's no simple answer to these
questions because they apply to so many
different people each with its own her
own idiosyncratic ways of working and
thinking and they in specific styles and
activities that range from the most
ingenious untutored craftsmen who think
in terms of the world in which they've
been brought up and inventors to all
manner of scientists and engineers who
think in very specialized worlds a
chemist for example whose inventive
lives in the world of chemicals and
symbols and spinning atoms and he
creates in that world and writers and
filmmakers and scholars and just plain
human beings it's quite accurate though
I suppose an existentialist escape to
say that together we are indeed creating
the future sociologists who I often
think are wrong say that we are living
through a second Industrial Revolution
propelled by communications and
computers
control systems basically an information
revolution in which human in the first
Industrial Revolution humans expanded
their physical capacities that has
multiplied their muscle power by
creating machine that machines that
harnessed energy extracted from nature
found in waterfalls and fossil fuels and
now in the atomic core to do much of
society's work and to expand vastly
their mobility and the result of that
has been a liberation from drudgery and
poverty to an increase in individual
productivity I don't like the word
revolution because it was more of an
evolution over a very long time and I
think we're engaged in a second
evolutionary cycle and when people say
revolution expect everything to happen
fast and even to be right and I think
we're far from having exhausted
the capabilities of this new information
communications revolution and in fact I
think the most imaginary things we could
say will turn out to be not fall far
short of what is probably real possible
if Tom Watson was here today and he
couldn't come I would tell you about his
prediction in 1947 that the world could
probably absorb five computers but since
he's not here I won't tell you about
today's symposium is examining one facet
of that Second Industrial Revolution or
evolution we're leaving out in our
discussions such things as robots and
bookkeeping machines and a lot of other
things which have become so vastly
important to our society and we're going
to concentrate symposium is
concentrating and I am concentrating on
how we can enhance human
abilities and like the media laboratory
itself today's symposium is intended to
explore the scope and potential of the
emerging areas of information technology
broadly speaking communications and
computing and because walter rosenblith
told you about our serendipitous
interaction with Norbert Wiener
at the end of World War two I will save
a little time and not do that but our
eyes were opened by Norbert maybe too
far I began to see the whole world as a
communication process even an electron
talking to the proton after all
communicating something and when I
worked it was a bad thing for me when I
worked in Washington because I see now I
believe all social processes our
communication processes and one day
President Kennedy said to me why were
you smiling so while we were talking
about that terrible disaster we're
dealing with I said I didn't realize I
was smiling and he said what were you
thinking about and I said well I told
him my view that individuals societies
if cells were now learning are all
communicating devices and as Norbert
Weiner said if it wasn't for
communications and information life
itself could not exist I guess I was
dreaming about how we were dealing with
an information process that we should
have dealt with two years ago how the
time the feedback cycle had been so long
that the government was now trying to
contend with a problem that it was
impossible to solve and we just had to
live with the disaster that a little bit
like South Africa that we had not been
perceptive enough to catch early enough
to do anything about and I think that's
the nature of our society and as it's
become more complex as a scale has grown
as transportation and information have
shrunk the world is struggling
struggling to somehow learn
how to keep the excursions down mr.
southern used the word which is a
perfect description of what we hope we
are creating a place where
experimentation can occur involving men
and machines and certainly in the arts
but we hope in many other fields like
learning to and maybe we can even help
in our efforts to improve the human
machine interrelation everyone who uses
computers but I regard the Wiener images
have made me believe that all of life
all of society is an experimental
learning process and I wish the
politicians would learn that lesson
because they either believe when they
start out to do something that they have
the answer or if they don't believe it
they feel they have to make believe they
have it which means that things can go
very badly wrong before they are willing
to perceive an error and make a
correction
whereas in science we're we're mostly
used to having our experiments come off
in a different direction than we
intended often we learn something and we
get our credit and not for just credit
not for having made a bad mistake but
for being the first to perceive it if
you're the last who is willing to admit
that what you're doing is wrong it
pretty fast lose your reputation as a
scientist but if you're willing to be
among the first to recognize what's
going on then you don't have a problem
the media laboratory is a product of the
MIT culture and I must say if I can go
back to Jim Williams introduction that
it is the MIT culture and not
individuals that is the important thing
mit is a place where anybody who makes a
modicum of sense can do anything he
pleases almost he has to meet an
occasional class
and he shouldn't overrun his budgets too
far but it's a very encouraging very
enriching bring permissive environment
and my only goal as president aside from
raising money which is a natural
responsibility of a president was to be
an enthusiasm amplifier and hope that
people had the opportunities the to do
the things they want to do because I
believe so completely that the
experimental approach governed with a
little common sense and maybe even a
little theory is the only way
civilization makes proud progress and
the Media Lab is a place where creative
and curious people are exploring uses of
electronic media now the laboratory is a
direct consequence of the establishment
of the Council for the Arts by alumni
and Friends I said written slightly more
than a decade ago last night somebody
said it was 14 years ago to nourish the
Arts at MIT and at its initial meeting
two distinguished poets Stanley Kunitz
and Archibald MacLeish challenged us to
see science and the arts as a part of a
total human experience there was Stanley
Kunitz said in many disciplines but only
one imagination and that statement has
continued to resonate in my head as
we've talked about what we were doing in
the laboratory as we talk about
educational reform as we talk about what
the goal of a good education is what he
was saying is the head can store many
different kinds of information but
somehow it has only one process for
bringing it all together and to me that
meant the more you have the more
different things you have in your head
more you understand all the totality of
life's experiences a greater chance you
have of being a truly creative
contributing citizen Archibald MacLeish
pushed us further and he argued that
humanity could only be saved by bringing
science and the arts together again
that's a pretty tall order
he was obviously looking back to the
19th century humanist scientist who was
able to encompass all that was known and
we'll have to do a lot of abstracting
maybe your lab can help do that in order
to meet that goal
the electronic information revolution
started kind of innocently with the
invention of the Telegraph and the
telephone followed by the wireless and
then picture transmission devices
including television these systems have
provided humans with global
communication capabilities some people
may want to challenge the positive
influence of all that but these were all
passive devices primarily able to get a
image or a voice or a message from one
place to another to extend the range of
the human senses the electronic computer
brought something very different and
some people recognized it very early
with its symbol manipulation capability
it provides a means to expand metal
powers and to do many routine mental
tasks and it's why I think we are indeed
experiencing the Second Industrial
Revolution without that active
participation active ability to
manipulate the store to find information
we would be in a very different stage in
the electrical communication business
we are just at its beginning the
beginning of this evolutionary period
and face the challenge of developing
much more effective systems and also of
adapting to the many opportunities
changes and problems that this will
leave in its wake one of the aspects of
information and computing developments
which are particularly intriguing to me
possibly because of Norbert wieners
interests in the way we structured the
research laboratory of electronics is
that many of the technical developments
mimic living systems so that in a sense
we are retracing nature's invention of
information and control system but with
some differences maybe one shouldn't be
surprised that we are mimicking living
systems because they're only systems
that we know now some people will be
offended by what I'm gonna say but I
think man-made systems use better
components electrical signals travel a
million times faster than signals on
nerve fibers and semiconductor devices
also act billions of times faster than
neurons which are the biological
information processing elements also
man-made elements appear to be more
reliable but Nature has a very large
edge maybe a decisive edge in design
complexity involving a number of
individual elements it can use it in a
system effectively and these are
advantages man may never match nature
may always retain this edge who knows
but for the moment it really doesn't
matter the man-made systems that we are
involved with enhance human creative
capacities that's what they can do
but so far they cannot displace them
cognitive and computer scientists are
having an exciting time trying to
understand and imitate human reasoning
with computing systems and though they
can do a few things that would be
regarded as thinking if done by a human
they differ violently among themselves
on whether or not machines
with human thinking and creative
abilities are possible even a so-called
artificial intelligence feel which
prompted north walter rosenblith to say
he preferred natural stupidity his
greatest achievement in this field is
capturing knowledge and skills of humans
act of human experts no matter what one
believes about the future it's perfectly
clear that such machines thinking
machines creative machines do not exist
No so I think I'm on safe ground if I
say at the moment that neither process
of thinking or the act of creation is
really understood so I can simplify this
discussion fortunately because I'm
probably running out of time by
eliminating any attempt to explore
either the act of creation itself or
machines that can think and limit myself
to the ways the many ways in which the
combination of computing and
communication as we know it now and can
expect it to evolve during the decades
ahead will expand the human creative
capacity the rapidly developing computer
and information sciences pervade almost
every discipline of study in one or two
ways and sometimes both through the use
of data and information processing
machines to facilitate the study of a
problem or through the concepts and I
think this is very important
seven firm ation and computing that help
people to understand are any previously
puzzling phenomena examples of this can
be seen in biology and the social
sciences in the study of languages and
connecting it and cognition and to a
degree not fully appreciated in the
study of computing and information
processes themselves and as this work
continues there is being created a new
scientific discipline focused on the
study of communications information
processing and cognitive processes now
we all know that the word computing does
not describe what a modern information
processing machine can do computing
calls to mind number crunching
in fact the goodness of a computer and
there's that word again computer it's
generally measured by the number of
millions of arithmetic operations it can
perform a second even if it is being
used for the composition of music or
they help an astronomer find a black
hole in a cosmic haystack or to assist a
physician and seeing a picture of the
brain or help an electrical engineer to
make a better information switching
system Arthur
Kessler in his book the act of creation
argues quite convincingly that novel
creations of the mind require the
intersection of two normally unrelated
sets of ideas or metal fields and that's
why he says most creative products from
puns and bad jokes to the most enjoyable
music art or scientific discovery or
even engineering design contain an
element that they all have in common
they all give an element of joy when
they are experienced or beheld and what
I believe the role of the machine
all of our laboratory in a sense is to
increase the size the metal fields
available to an individual and to
increase the probability that the
searching human mind will provide
productive or will find productive
intersections the fact sherry Turkle
this morning expanded my vision of the
problem we have a mismatch input and
output system the visual system takes in
information at a fantastic rate and when
we try to put it down we use this
particular part of the human system that
wasn't designed for rapid transmission
of information it gets very tired if you
use it very long or try to put he took
the whole field of one television
picture and tried to write it out you
would have a sore arm and so in a sense
we're trying to contend with that
mismatch in which the human creative
mind
in fact can't get information can't ask
questions fast enough can't output
fastness and kessler's insight to the
creative process is supported by an
examination of creativity in many areas
and in particular the artists and
dependence upon familiar themes I hope I
don't offend all the artists present
most owls I believe have an element of
autobiography or at least biography
artists have styles that they find hard
to leave behind that is essentially
transfer functions that are their
signatures scientists tend to use the
same techniques and approaches that were
successful on earlier problems even when
the new ones are very different and
their trials continue to fail
it should be clear I think why I avoided
any attempt to explore the act of
creation itself or machines that can
think and just explore the ways in which
the combination of computing and
communications as we know it now and
expect it to evolve can so we vastly
expand the human creative capacity
I think computing can aid the creative
process in several distinct ways and in
order for you to have an afternoon
meeting I'm going to list the ways and
ask you to accept this and think of your
own examples and not read mine but my
first is by vastly expanding the scope
of traditional creative activities by
making possible calculations that far
far exceed unaided human capacity as
well as facilitating other traditional
texts and tasks such as searching
indexes storing and retrieving large
files and so on we all know anyone as
old as me can remember the computing
rooms full of faculty wives were turning
cranks on programs that were monitored
by the scientist who was trying her
engineer who was trying to get some
numbers out of his experiments or
calculations and that really limited the
scope of scientific inquiry of
engineering design and that limitation
has almost disappeared the fact is that
the human mind can always find a problem
that's bigger than the tools we have
available and I'm sure the computer
manufacturers love that but the fact is
that very few real scientific analysis
or engineering design problems are now
limited by computing power the second
way of our already alluded to
and that is by providing new cognitive
tools new models for thinking about
problems that involve information such
as understanding speech or the genetic
code or thinking and creating processes
themselves and many others the economic
models that we hear so much about and
don't know how to interpret this
provides a basis for thinking about
problems and which symbols and their
relationships and their identity rather
than the physical properties of systems
are significant and finally by providing
wholly new media and techniques to be
used in the creative process and this
category includes many of the electronic
systems that allow new forms of design
music making modeling of both physical
and information systems and many of the
different uses of computing networks
explored this morning and I think with
that thought namely that we have an
open-ended future that the computer
gives us these opportunities and
challenges us to understand how to use
it more effectively in augmenting the
human creative power I will stop and go
hear what others have to say thank you
very much
you